robble robble america haha I am back
okay we get it
you're back but who the hell are you
McDonald's is creeping everyone out with
this new Hamburglar campaign where the
skies says he's come back to steal
burgers or something but uh he's really
obviously not the same guy that used to
do this we don't know if he murdered the
original guy or what but I'm on a lorry
same one that I've always been and we've
got all the evidence that something is
seriously wrong here this is hashtag
news
this is a picture of the hamburger that
we all grew up knowing and loving not
loving just knowing but that's who the
Hamburglar used now this weirdo felon
disappeared from all McDonald's ads back
in 2003 which was a good move because as
at Tyler small points out one of
McDonald's mascots is a guy who steals
McDonald's yeah fire that guy then last
week
McDonald's started teasing that he was
coming back but that this is what he
looks like now
okay so sure he's kind of hot in a bad
boy with a five o'clock shadow kind of
way but there's no way we're supposed to
just accept that this is the same guy
the original Hamburglar wasn't a freakin
human look here he is hanging out with
Ronald McDonald who was ripping his
tribe Sanders closing something but
Ronald obviously a real human man
wearing a ton of makeup and Hamburglar
is clearly not he doesn't even speak
real words he just says robble robble
relevantly you got a weirdo plastic head
and like maybe in this universe I could
buy that he's like some sort of cool
creature but that is not a human if we
are supposed to buy that this is the
same guy he's just taller now and had a
bunch of plastic surgery or something
they're doing the same thing that
Wendy's did that girl looks nothing like
Wendy and here he is hiding his criminal
activities from his wife
hi honey I am actually at a party store
right now so I can take care of it
I hope they don't try to have kids
because plastic surgery can change your
genes and the baby's gonna have a cap a
plastic hat or something yes son what
and he's normal looking yeah that's
obviously not his real kid there is so
much drama in this family or he used to
wear the plastic head and now he doesn't
anymore or he's the son of the hamburger
who used to wear them plots against also
he's a father and husband ideas criminal
alter-ego from his family basically he's
Walter White and if that's true you know
he's not doing this to make his family's
life any easier you did this for the
family I did it for me I liked it
rebel rebel I don't know I'm gonna stop
hating this could just be the first
reboot launching a whole new MCU that's
MacDonald's Cinematic Universe
maybe the whole crew will be getting
reimagined into a bunch of sexy
fast-food Avengers I'd be totally down
with a funky purple grimace movie he's
not human either well we don't there's
not laws set up I got that yet you
should subscribe right now go for it
click oh also please comment and let us
know what you think of the new
Hamburglar because I'm not convinced and
don't forget to hello what no of course
I don't lead a secret life has a web
show host
go back to bed Margaret I'll be home
soon Margaret your daughter your wife
wouldn't you like to know yeah that's
why I asked she's my cat